ich habe am anfang mal wieder ziemlich
viel scheiße gelabert also wenn ihr
keinen bock darauf habt mir am anfang zu
zuhören das video geht ungefähr bei
minute 3 oder solos ja jetzt viel spaß
ach so der läuft ja schon etwas glauben
es bekommt bei video mkv quietsche stuhl
schon besser was gedacht herzlich
willkommen bei diesem neuen video und
ihr habt sie wahrscheinlich am titel
schon gelesen es gibt heute endlich den
zweiten part von die berühmtesten
musicals der welt der letzte pass
einfach so unglaublich fakten gut bei
euch angekommen
ich meine ich hab ich gesagt bei 15.000
likes ich merke man kann einfach hier
ein
ich habe mir glaub ich gesagt bei 15.000
likes oder 20.000 die 12.000 ich glaube
es waren 15.000 auf keine art auf jeden
fall bei 15.000 likes wäre der zweite
teil kommen aber er wird so karlsböck
braucht ihr habt nicht 15.000 sein
lassen sondern einfach 40.000 sind
einfache das ist so caspar also danke ja
deswegen bin ich hier in ungewohnter
umgebung in ein baum wo eigentlich eine
wand hinten dran ist aber eigentlich ist
das gar keine band sondern nur eine
tapete mit einer band ja genau so meine
ich dass und wie es wahrscheinlich schon
gesehen habt ich war gerade endlich nach
zwei oder drei monaten mal wieder beim
friseur hab ich ihnen danke danke danke
nur was mich ein bisschen gewundert als
ich bin gerade in köln bei mir zuhause
zahle ich für eine neue frisur 14 euro
in köln zahle ich einfach praktisch ohne
scheint sich meine tüte das gemacht hat
was war mega cool und ich finde es auch
gut gelungen so werden ein paar tipps
gegeben als wenn die bisschen länger
sind wieder sieht megaforce hoffe ich
mal wo ich meine du hast auch nur die
seite gestellt hat denkst du wer du
scheiße ich habe ihn sogar gesagt wie
ich auf youtube heißt nach ägypten
nein spaß wenn du hast es schön gruselig
ich komme auf jeden fall nächste mal
wieder du hast echt gut
und ja ich heute mal wieder vor dem
thema vorbei auf jeden fall gibt es
heute die berühmtesten musicals part 2
und ja ich weiß ja untermain letzten
teil geschrieben so ja es gibt noch viel
berühmtere deswegen habe ich gesagt dann
schickt
normal und ihr habt mir wirklich bei
instagram so viele musiker die ich mit
zig millionen leipzig ich habe den
fahrer von rausgesucht die mir am besten
gefallen haben die zeiten da kenne ich
auch noch nicht und mal gucken ob er das
ein oder andere wieder nach stellt
völlig weiß es nicht ich will gar nicht
eingelagert ich würde sagen bei 15.000
sagen wir 20.000 20.000 lies gibt's
nochmal sonderfolge ich denke das
schaffen wir wieder fangen wir anders
nach oben obwohl erst wenn euch das
video gefällt und macht ja keinen sinn
dafür ist ja der daumen nach oben
und ich sehe jetzt schon wieder die
kommentare dollar was auch einfach viel
zu viel
ich war es okay
ok den kenne ich noch aus der letzten
folge das ist nämlich cameron diaz mein
baby habe ich ganz oft in den
kommentaren gelesen und zwar ist das
anteil von ziemlich vielen von euch euer
baby und den kammern
das darf auf keinen fall was sagen weil
sonst kriegt ärger von euch dieses
musical hat einfach 669 millionen likes
das letzte von der matte 1,5 millionen
aber woher soll ich denn wissen dass die
arbeit mit 669 millionen und nur weil
ich im letzten video irgendwie so sein
musical die nach gemacht habe und dass
ein bisschen schlecht dargestellt habe
ich habe natürlich überhaupt nicht ich
habe vollstes speck freue mich meint es
zwanzig mal so bekannt wie ich dicker
wollen wir tauschen
deswegen schönes musik hat mir gefallen
aber was soll ich dazu sagen wir machen
meint mit lisa und lena
wann dieser arena
irgendwie sieht genauso aus das team
jetzt mit keine ahnung wer ihr seid aber
kommt anscheinend gut andere ich meine
man muss nur gleich aussehen und man
hätte ich mal zwillinge das meine ich
jetzt nicht böse ich meine ich will ja
nicht
lisa und lena feuerwerk wie schlecht
darstellen
mir macht weiter mit dem nicht beim
zweiten mal war es nicht mehr so wird
sich mit dem wasser
das machen wir nochmal kurz
muss man jetzt nicht verstehen aber ich
finde es kreativ ich finds gut okay
leute und jetzt kommen wir zu dem
berühmten ich habe jetzt es war schon
gesagt so jetzt kommen wir zu den
berühmtesten musiker die auch ganz music
ally das auf den 4,5 millionen likes
aber ihr habt mich da zurecht gewiesen
hat gesagt herr alex es gibt noch ein
video das hat elf millionen
und da dachte ich elf millionen likes
kommt alle her das guck mal ich jetzt
mal ich denke zwar auch dass die meisten
euch das kennen sollten ich kann es auch
ich wusste nur nicht dass das so viele
leute
mama mama kommst revier müssen wir eben
im musical die nahtstellen gekommen
ich finde es echt gut also ich finde für
sowas ist ja so eine plattform
geschaffen und ich für acht ihren
oberkörper frei von der kamera um haben
wir noch ihre zunge rausstrecken also
das war echt ein geistig wirklich und
von dieser wirklich kreativen sorte habe
ich noch ein zweites gefunden was auch
ziemlich bekannt ist und wirklich
saugeil also wirklich geil gemacht so
ich kann das glaube ich nicht also das
ist echt krass
dafür brauchen wir wirklich ich meine
wieder läufst du dafür gebraucht so der
der wahl an 20 verschiedenen orten und
hat immer weiß nicht was geht ineinander
immer ich finds geil und ich werde ja
nicht alex wenn ich auch was rausgesucht
was ich heute mal wieder nach tanzen
kann und das ist voll ist
ernster was habe ich mir vorgenommen
das war schon mal falsch
keine ahnung ich bin einfach komplett
überfordert ich denke an die partie
schach so die hat wahrscheinlich auch
mit zeitnahme
hey leute ich gebe ehrlich da muss ja
drei jahre film ist es klappt und wie
fandet jetzt nicht so
ja ich habe ja auch nicht gesagt ist gut
wird von dem jetzt folgenden war ich
auch echt begeistert so ach so 1,3 mio
alles klar also du kannst dich echt gut
bewegen mehr wollen nicht dazu auch gar
nicht so das war's mit diesem video ich
hoffe natürlich es hat genau wie beim
letzten mal aufgefallen und was ich
jetzt noch sagen wollte mich vergessen
ach so leute was ich noch schnell
loswerden wollte habe ich auch schon
10.000 mal gesamten irgendwie es aber
ich habe auch musicali zusammen mit
meiner freundin da waren wir wie ich den
aufwendigsten cicek ist auf jeden fall
mal aufs alex nicht alexander zimmer
sondern an ist ja genau ich würde sagen
bei 20 millionen likes machen wir das
ganze noch mal ihr könnt mir wieder
einfach bei instagram direkte heißt ich
einfach alexander v also alex wie könnt
ihr mir weitere berühmte und bekannte
musicals schicken hätte ich auf jeden
fall bei snap chat da bin ich jetzt
wieder mega aktiv und mehr wollte ich
gar nicht sagen
auch wenn ich schon wieder zu viel
gesagt habe wir sehen uns morgen 19 uhr
neues video und ich glaube
wahrscheinlich schon wieder auf den keks
jetzt muss ich einfach ganz ohne tische
rennen schon sagen kann line hieß